so the second part of the trump elaine
maxwell story
is about what trump meant by i wish her
well now i already laid out for you
how on tuesday at donald trump's
coronavirus press briefing he was asked
about the arrest of jilane maxwell
uh the alleged groomer and trafficker of
girls for jeffrey epstein trump
bizarrely wished her well
and then said he doesn't know anything
about the connection between prince
andrew and jeffrey epstein
in the last segment we focused on
showing you in 2015
trump certainly knew about the
connection between prince andrew and
jeffrey epstein
let's now talk about uh i wish her well
take a look at this clip
just lane maxwell is in prison and a lot
of people want to know
if she's going to turn in powerful
people and i know you've talked in the
past about prince andrew
and you've criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach but i
wish her well
whatever it is i don't know the
situation with prince andrew just don't
know not aware of it
now a lot of people wrote to me saying
isn't it really weird
that donald trump asked about someone
accused of
horrible crimes right serial sex
trafficking and grooming of young women
and girls
wishing her well that's weird well of
course it's weird but donald trump is a
weird guy he has a different moral code
than many of us have but there's a
different perspective from donald
trump's former aide and very brief white
house communications director anthony
scaramucci who tweeted about this
and scaramucci says trump is wishing her
well
not to wish her well it's code for her
not to talk
in other words don't cooperate don't
tell investigators what you know
about trump's activities possible
activities with jeffrey epstein
and scaramucci tweeted in the morning
earlier this week
quote she has the goods on him he is
signaling
please don't talk now of course it's
speculative but also of course if indeed
there's some connection that involves
donald trump and jeffrey epstein
there's no shortage of such allegations
donald trump has shown that he is very
much willing to reward people
who stay quiet with either pardons or
commuting their sentences
if you believe that trump wishing her
well is a signal
that she should stay quiet there's
really an implicit threat there sort of
like a mafia boss suggesting that the
guy who got arrested hopefully is going
to have good luck
right which means don't say a word
donald trump has used similar language
to other associates who have been
indicted michael flynn
roger stone paul manafort he's talked
about wishing them good luck
wishing them the best i hope for the
best for them so
there's a degree of speculation here on
the other hand you could say
of course that's what trump is doing and
it's completely obvious like there are
on the one hand there's people saying
this is sort of speculative
on the other hand there's people saying
clearly this is what trump is doing and
that's exactly what he's signaling to
her by saying i wish her well
now to go back to the beginning and the
sort of bizarre nature
of trump wishing well to a serial
accused
child sex trafficker just imagine what
would have happened if barack obama was
asked about someone
who had been accused of supplying
underage girls for people to sexually
assault
and obama had said i wish them well
think just for a second
about what fox news and all right wing
media would have done
for days if barack obama had done that
and you remember you know this myth of
the liberal media
uh just instantly crumbles before our
very eyes so in terms of
you know do i expect we're going to get
public news of any kind of allegation
from jilane maxwell about donald trump
before the election i really don't
there is a contingent that believes the
timing of this
elaine maxwell thing is exactly so that
in mid-september late september early
october
there's just blockbuster allegations
made about donald trump and his
connection to jeffrey epstein
part of why i i mean listen i don't know
if there
that there is such a plan i actually
don't know that it would make a
difference at this point
trump was accused before being elected
president by 16
20 women i mean subsequently in books
that came out
that number went to 30 40 something
women who have accused trump of
different degrees of
sexual assault up to and including rape
and
trump's approval and his polling started
to suffer
when he failed on coronavirus when he
failed on the economic response to
coronavirus
when he responded to protests against
police brutality by threatening to
and actually sending in federal troops
so not only am i not sitting around
waiting for that to happen in terms of
julian maxwell
i don't even know that it would make
much of a difference i think that the
real issues continue to be
the ones that people tell us they are if
you look at recent polling the three
issues hurting trump are
virus response economic response
and response to the george floyd protest
slash race relations
i don't even know that this is really
what we need more allegations from
julian maxwell if she has them to make
she should make them and they should be
reported on
but waiting for that as what's going to
knock trump out of office
his supporters have shown they don't
care about that and i think that that's
the approach that we should have
if you disagree with me let me know i'm
on twitter at dpakman also remember that
you can get the daily
every single weekday monday through
friday daily audio podcast
for free on any podcast app
that you prefer itunes beautiful
spotify available google play podcasts
have added haas the daily audio podcast
typically released
at 3 p.m eastern every day we'll take a
quick break
and be back after this if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can
get through in just 15 minutes and you
get all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video